y
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
en esta emisión vamos a ecuador y lo
hacemos para hablar sobre la crítica
situación del sistema carcelario en este
país una crisis que tuvo uno de sus
episodios más sangrientos a fines de
septiembre cuando un motín en una cárcel
de guayaquil dejó más de 100 personas
muertas una crisis que además visibiliza
las condiciones en las que viven las
personas que están privadas de su
libertad en ecuador y en esta emisión
vamos a enfocarnos en uno de los
sectores más vulnerables de la población
carcelaria estamos hablando del
colectivo lgtb de pumas y por eso nos
acompaña odalys cayambe ella es mujer
trans ex presidiaria en ecuador y
también activista y directora de la
organización vivir libre que hace parte
de la red comunitaria trans de ecuador y
que se dedica a asistir a la población
carcelaria el eje vehículo en este país
odalys muchísimas gracias por tu
presencia en la entrevista de france 24
qué tan muy buenas tardes saludos
gracias por la invitación no gracias a
ti por favor la situación de la
población lgtb está en ecuador como
decíamos ya es crítica en libertad
recordemos además que en ecuador la
homosexualidad se despenalizó en recién
en 1997 no hay leyes ni políticas
públicas específicas para las personas
trans en este contexto cuál es la
situación actual de las personas trans
en el país y en particular en sus
cárceles
bueno como los mencionaste del 97 se
desperdició la base sólida en ecuador lo
cual no hace una garantía de vida para
ninguna de nosotras desde el mismo
inning el registro del estado no habla
de una claridad sobre los cuerpo y la
vida trans imagínate el ser una mujer
trans lgbt y priva de libertad es vivir
en un total abandono y olvido estatal es
el ser priva de libertad
uno por decir yo siempre hemos dicho
nosotros culpable o no ya estamos paga
una sentencia lo cual nosotros lo que
buscamos dentro de estos de estos
organismos del sistema de rehabilitación
social es que se cumplan las garantías
en las mujeres trans entre ellas los
llamados reglamentos penitenciarios
algo que no se cumple dentro del sistema
entonces bien crítica la situación algo
no nuevo todo lo que ha pasado pero la
situación sigue siendo muy crítica
dentro de ellos ahora hay en otro caso
en particular valleys y por supuesto
hasta donde quieras y hasta donde puedes
contarnos cuando nos cuál fue tu
experiencia personal mientras estuviste
privada de tu libertad en una entrevista
contaste que llegaste a tener cierto
comportamiento incluso para que te
declararán local no se te acercará a
nadie
bueno mi proceso de vida yo yo siempre
he dicho yo hablo de nuestra
organización la red trabaja de la
realidad de cada una son las comunidades
esas comunitarias y yo no siempre es mi
realidad yo desde mi temprana edad yo
accionamos el tranque vengo viviendo de
los 11 años el sistema de violencia en
calle y el sistema penitenciario de los
13 14 15 y 68 años tiene una niña en
adolescente trans vivió todo este
sistema y mi adulta es como yo siempre
digo volví a recibir el sistema
primero por ser trabajadora sexual por
ser trans y ahora mi adultez por ser
buena gente bueno culpable no igual ya
estuve y apagué mi proceso entre todo
esto nació vivi libre basada en la
violencia sistemática que viven que
viven y viven aún las mujeres trans
privada de libertad en lo cual desde mi
mi personal yo como me ves
visibilizado siempre como una mujer está
de mi niñez fue el sistema algo que el
estado no lo quiso evidenciar ya está
documentada legalmente como dalí es
callarme el estado me obligó a
identificarme masculinamente porque
entre comillas yo no hicieron un sistema
para mujeres trans ni para él el sistema
está hecho para hombre o mujer más no
bajo un contexto de defensa para nuestra
población que somos vulnerables dentro
del sistema entonces de toda esta
iniciativa de mi propia experiencia tuve
que comenzar tuve muchos tropiezos como
mujer trans nunca respetaron mi derecho
a la identidad mi derecho a la vida y
sobre todo a la expresión de género que
está contemplado en la constitución del
artículo 11 numeral 2 pues se debe
respetar mi condición y expresión de
género así no tengo una identidad algo
que no hace el sistema con las mujeres
trans el eje bética en el sistema lo
cual las obliga a vivir todo un sistema
que lo normado patriarcado totalmente es
que enunció amigo violencia y esto hizo
que nosotros comenzamos a incidir dentro
de mi propia experiencia me encabezado
era por uno si era él por presunta
explotación sexual una sentencia mínima
de
de 6 años lo cual no me conllevaba que a
mí me lleven a máxima seguridad me
llevaron a vivir tuvo una ola de
violencia con personas que tenía un
índice selectivo sumamente alto o sea
nada que ver con mi contexto de vida lo
cual desde ahí como contraste me tocó
pedir ayuda porque el centro no quería
ayudar porque ellos fueron claros al
decir que el sistema estaba hecho para
hombres no para mujeres trans ni para el
glp sino para hombres y como tal me
estaban tratando entonces gracias a una
psicólogo que no sabes que la única
forma que tengas que salir de aquí
haciéndote la loca yo te puedo sacar de
este sistema amiga es que te hagas loca
lo cual a mí me tocó no bañarme estar
encerrado en celo mínimo como tres meses
que tocó auto yo mismo flagelarme para
que así el sistema pueda verme de una
forma donde me puede llevar a que
nosotros tanto peleaban hoy sabíamos que
existía pero no se aplicaba como en el
trato prioritario desde ahí nosotros
comenzamos a incidir todas violencia que
vivimos las mujeres tras el trato humano
que no se adentró la esclavitud que
todavía existe en las mujeres trans la
violencia sistemática que es práctica de
diferentes puntos comenzamos trabar todo
esto basado en la violencia que aún se
vive ahora hablemos de otro punto una
vez libre es odalys si ser trans implica
tener muchísimas menos posibilidades
ahora a ser una mujer trans con
antecedentes penales imagino que debe
ser muchísimo peor en este sentido hay
un doble estigma
por supuesto que sí es un súper
complejísimo la vida sobre todo las
mujeres trans privar en libertad es una
etiqueta que no te deja ni suscribir y
así nosotros no tenemos un registro de
ley de trabajo no tenemos un registro de
ley de salud o no tenemos un registro de
ley de seguro social un seguro imagínate
que se priva de libertad nosotros
vivimos en una violencia continua y con
un abandono social porque la sociedad no
perdona no perdona el hecho que nosotros
queramos vivir como nos vemos como
sentimos y más gente se me van a
perdonar a muchas saliendo con un
grillete en las piernas y a otras sin
ningunas oportunidades es por esto que
se vive la re distinción en personaje l
vete al sistema porque encima que no hay
un verdadero sistema de rehabilitación
social la sociedad discrimina humilla
maltrata lo cual las chicas vuelven a
recibir el sistema porque es como una
élite que ahí mismo está mientras no
haya una educación de verdad las mujeres
trans no vamos a vivir sobre todo las es
priva de libertad con una sentencia
digna que a pesar que dentro de las dice
que el estado debe hacer un
acompañamiento después de un año la
priva de libertad algo que jamás hacen y
lo que pasa resultado es una extinción
nuevamente el sistema o vivir en calle y
violencia
vinculado a estos que estás hablando
sobre la reinserción que es clave y es
hacia donde deberían apuntar por
supuesto las prisiones desde la red
comunitaria trans de ecuador- ustedes
están ayudando muchísimo en este sentido
con casas de acogida verdad para ex
presidiarias porque el nivel de
reincidencia es bastante alto no estamos
hablando que muchísimas personas que al
salir no tienen trabajos no tienen un
círculo que desde contención tampoco
desde otros puntos
nosotros comenzamos dentro del sistema
vivir libre inició desde 2013 avanzaron
la violencia que vivió la lista llave y
que vivió un grupo de mujeres trans y lg
betis dentro del sistema y nosotros
seguimos esto ya trabajando somos un
grupo de 13 mujeres trans a nivel
nacional ex privada de libertad porque
somos la red la red trans los cuales
nosotros trabajamos pensando desde desde
adentro porque la restricción porque las
compañeras a pesar que acá las que
adentro las cogen como muy humanas las
cogen como empleadas las cogen como la
chica de trabajo sexual no remunerada
sin número de violencia vuelven a
reincidir es porque el sistema no
trabaja con políticas claras uno sale a
la calle no encuentra trabajo
uno tiene que volver a ejercer el
trabajo sexual imagínate si una es
criminalizada por ser trabajo sexual
meses por ser ex pp l entonces cuando
salen a la calle de una vez son llevadas
retenes son otra vez llevadas por un
proceso judicial
todas estas cuestiones ya que las chicas
muchas y en realidad me da mucha pena 7
que muchos la población trans lgbt vivan
en situación de calle o la porto por el
abandono total que existe a la población
trans privada de libertad
es una suerte de condena ahora quisiera
preguntarte lo siguiente sobre esto ya
estuvimos charlando un poco no pero esa
falta de reconocimiento de lo que es su
identidad en ecuador se traduce en lo
que pasa en las cárceles donde alguna
mujer trans como bien decía vos comparte
el espacio con varones heterosexuales o
sea que están conviviendo con el sector
que más violencia ejerce sobre ustedes y
además en un contexto de encierro y de
aislamiento
esto implica estar como decías expuestas
a todo tipo de violencia que van desde
negarle su identidad hasta los abusos
físicos que vos mismas relatadas qué
efectos puede tener esto en lo que es su
autopercepción hoy en su propia
valoración de ustedes mismas
las chicas bueno te hago como privada de
libertad porque todavía lo sigo haciendo
por el estado te comento la percepción
en nosotras de muchas es un ciclo es un
ciclo lo cual muchas salen con ganas de
debilitarse de vivir una vida totalmente
libre de violencia pero la verdad el
sistema no lo deja mientras el estado no
cumpla con garantías claras en la
población trans mientras la gente en
ecuador deje de ver mucho más allá del
97 una recolección de firmas las mujeres
están sobre todo las que viven y más
violencia que son las ex privadas la
clave privada de libertad no van a tener
ni un contexto de vida más con la
restricción y como yo siempre dicho
ecuador solamente lleva una organización
que trabaja en ellas que somos nosotras
que tratamos de buscar desde la casa de
acogida el proceso del laboral el
proceso educativo el proceso el proceso
de salud y el proceso de duke del
proceso deportivo pero esa es
competencia del estado con lo cual el
estado ni siquiera quieren ni garantizar
la vida de las mujeres te anima gente
con nosotros expectativas claras otra
vez enrumbarnos sobre todo en el tema de
la visibilidad para que se comiencen a
reconocer los cuerpos y la vida tan
desde cualquier trayectoria de cualquier
punto las privadas libertad a las
adultas mayores
la niñez de la adolescencia tras las
pruebas bueno tengo unas situaciones y
mujeres trans que estamos en líneas pero
somos invisibilizadas rural y es que
allá de muchísimas gracias por tu
presencia la entrevista de france 24 ha
sido un placer dialogar contigo
realmente
a usted muchas gracias gracias a ti
nuevamente ya nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
sigan con nosotros
[Música]
y